oh baby all I want for
Christmas can I put a pause here it's a
Bop it's a great song and it's it's
actually acceptable to play now you know
I'm a big stickler on don't play
Christmas music during Advent this isn't
a Christmas song this is an advent song
it's an advent song because it is a song
in anticipation of Christmas she's not
saying I'm so glad what I got for
Christmas was you it's not it's all I
want for Christmas what I'm Desiring as
I look forward in this season toward
Christmas is you it's Advent so it
checks that box now it's a secular song
right yeah but look there are plenty of
great secular Christmas songs not as
important as say silent night but
they're good songs not as good as a des
[Music]
Fel but you know pretty good